voilà vais rien et madame sage brigneau
ce sont les deux rapporteurs du texte de
notre commission une partie du ce texte
qui concerne l'éducation a été déléguée
à la commission d'éducation et c'est
notre collègue monsieur pieds noirs qui
le rapporteur mais n'est pas là ce matin
puisqu'il auditionnera de son côté nous
allons vous laisser la parole pour vous
nous donner votre point de vue sur ce
texte
et puis ensuite il ya évidemment une
série de questions on essaie de tenir
dans un délai de 50 minutes
voilà pour être un point devient alors
vous avez la parole je vous remercie
notre présence également j'ai oublié de
le faire tu pouvais m'en excuser
entre leone et on peut se permettre ce
cher monsieur le président votre secret
pas trop merci beaucoup
président de ma parole à après une
longue démarche de travail sur un texte
qui à mon sens n'a jamais été aussi
préparé en amont par les cultes et à
travers vous je veux remercier toute la
représentation nationale sénat
l'assemblée le gouvernement différents
intervenants sur cette loi d'avoir
autant associés les cultes et je trouve
que c'est c'est sain et c'est en même
temps une façon de les aborder une loi
qui qu'ils soient là l'émanation de ce
que la société a besoin
je crois que nous sommes dans une
position devons faire quelque chose
collectivement je vous fabriquez la loi
en tout cas vous écrivez vous la rédiger
votre compte vous contribuez à la rendre
effective et c'est quelque chose
d'important on a on a assassiné des gens
en france on a décapité un professeur on
peut pas rester sans rien faire je crois
que et je le dis après mes amis
catholiques qui sont passés devant moi
et quelques instants que j'ai croisés
dans couloir les catholiques nous ont
remis lundi ce lundi un texte incroyable
sur leur engagement à lutter contre
l'antisémitisme qu'elle nécessitait
avait-il aujourd'hui de le faire aucune
simplement ils se sont dit attention on
commence à s'habituer
c'est ce que disait péguy il y a pire
que les âmes perverse il ya les âmes
habitué et je me dis que si on commence
dans le pays à s'habituer à une forme de
de violence et qui ferait qu'un jour on
en vienne à se dire bon maintenant qu'on
a moins d'attentats que telle année eh
ben ça va ce serait dramatique
et je me dis il faut faire quelque chose
il se trouve qu'en france c'est
peut-être un tort mais c'est comme ça en
france quand on veut faire quelque chose
on fait une loi et donc moi je suis pour
ce principe de rappeler les principes
républicains je suis tellement
dans les travaux préparatoires notamment
auprès des pouvoirs publics
j'avais suggéré de ne pas être dans une
posture négative rappelez-vous départ on
parlait de loi contre le séparatisme et
j'avais suggéré dès le départ de faire
en sorte que ce soit une loi pour
quelque chose
lauréate ali pourquoi mais je pense
qu'on veut me lis toujours beaucoup plus
en étant pour quelque chose qu'en étant
contre quelque chose je crois avoir été
entendu avec d'autres
j'ai le sentiment que oui faire quelque
chose c'est à un moment aller à l'action
au delà de la parole et si j'ose vous
parler un peu de bible mais vraiment un
tout petit peu et je le fais en
d'ailleurs un stylo très républicain en
main donc ça compensera ce que je fais
de parler de bible dans cette assemblée
dans cette institution le le peuple juif
est engagé au pied du mont sinaï en
disant de choses nous ferons et nous
interpréterons et nous écouterons c'est
l'action qui démontre la vérité de nos
proclamation et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on arrive maintenant un temps de
l'action au delà qui aille au delà de la
parole le principe que je trouve plutôt
juste dans cette loi c'est un
rééquilibrage en fait une recherche de
cohérence entre la loi 1905 de 1915 le
principe c'est que pour faire du culte
en france où devait être sous le statut
1905 sauf mes amis catholiques qui ont
un statut de 1907
mais bon ça c'est les aléas de
l'histoire on en parlera si vous la
presse en revanche vous voulez faire du
culte et 1905 et dans les faits beaucoup
d'associations cultuelles moindre recul
puisque lengelé le joli raid 1 pour
répondre que j'ai répondu à notre
questionnaire qu'on m'avait proposé
ou on est à 90 % à peu près en 1905 le
principe s'il ya des gens qui font du
culte sous le chapeau donc j'avais pas
dire sous la kippa et sous le chapeau
d'une association loi 1901 sans aucune
des contraintes de la loi 1905
aucune et donc il faut de la cohérence
vous voulez faire du culte sous la loi
1901 et bien vous aurez les mêmes
contraintes que le en 1905
maintenant je ne suis pas contre je n'ai
jamais été contre d'entendre ce que par
exemple certains cultes demande et je le
demande parce qu'il ya une cohérence
aussi en cela c'est que prenons
l'exemple qui pas le mien celui du
secours catholique par exemple qui fait
du social
le secours catholique puisque c'est du
social ne pourrait pas le faire sous le
chapeau 1905
parce que l'objet en scène je peux pas
dire l'objet social mais c'est comme ça
l'objet social de 1905 c'est
exclusivement le culte mais est ce que
le social c'est à dire donner aux
pauvres
ce qu'on appellerait dans le jeu d'elena
tsédaka à la charité d'un christianisme
zakat dans l'islam ça ne relève pas du
spirituel du religieux
pour moi oui donc y aurait une logique à
ce que on élargissent le champ la
possibilité du statut 1905 pour y
inclure social mais c'est pas l'enjeu
l'enjeu ce que en réalité toutes les
organismes toutes les organisations en
on crée des des soeurs en 1901 qui font
le social mais je trouve légitime soit
recherche de cohérence de l'état de
vouloir que quiconque gère du culte sous
une noix est une association loi 1901
subissent les mêmes contraintes que les
associations sous la loi 1905
le principe du contrôle des flux
financiers ne me gêne absolument pas je
répondrais aussi peut-être je commençais
à répondre à vos questions pourquoi me
gêne pas parce que c'est pas
l'interdiction des flux financiers
venant de l'étranger
c'est le contrôle donc si ça et gêne
quelqu'un de dire d'où vient l'argent
bah c'est qu'il ya un problème puisqu'il
ya la maire d'une grande ville du nord
de la france qui rappelle souvent ce que
disait sa grand mère quand il ya du flou
c'est qu'il ya un loup
donc on voit ce que j'en dis
je dis simplement ça ne devrait gêner
personne de dire voilà d'où viennent les
fonds là ferrand un autre fonctionnement
alors si vous permettez je vais
reprendre votre questionnaire qui était
vraiment très très large et qui
permettait de répondre que les questions
vous demandez quelle appréciation
globale je porte sur le loi est-ce que
je partage le diagnostic qu'il sous tend
bien sûr oui je pense qu'il faut faire
quelque chose et le diagnostic est clair
il ya des pulsions séparatistes chez
certains et si vous lisez par exemple un
grand journal du matin le figaro de ce
matin vous verrez qu'il nomme très
clairement non seulement le séparatisme
islamistes mais il nomme très clairement
dans l'islam parce qu'il faut avait
jamais faire d'amalgamé avec l'islam
organisé en france
il nomme très clairement les trois
fédérations qui refuse de signer
en fait ce pacte républicain et moi je
me dis puisque la presse du matin john
lennon on pourrait déjà commencer par
régler cette question avant de taper sur
toulon mais et ceci dit la loi doit être
uniforme et il faut qu'elle soit capable
cette loi d'avoir un c'est de finesse
pour ne pas gêner ce qui s'applique
parfaitement à respecter tous les
principes républicains
donc oui le diagnostic est juste et il
faut à mon sens faire cette loi il ya ce
qu'elles sont intention qui organise le
culte ou au regard d'une 105e j'en ai
parlé oui il faut une recherche de
cohérence entre les associations qui
font du culte 1901 1905
comment je juge les évolutions proposées
en matière de droit des associations
cultuelles
quel sera pour vous l'impact en termes
de création obligations déclaration
préalable de la qualité cultuelle là
encore le travail en amont qui a été
fait par les cultes a permis de faire
que cette demande de déclaration
préalable auprès du préfet ne soit
effective que pour les associations qui
ont moins de 15 ans d'existence c'est à
dire qu'on va reconnaître l'historicité
des associations leur engagement leur
patrimoine je dirais
leur adn d'une certaine manière et donc
on n'aura pas besoin de se justifier en
permanence pour dire que lowe's et le
casino jasor au consistoire restent
fidèles à leur objectif je me permets
ici de rappeler avec bonheur la devise
du consistoire religion et patrie ce qui
laisse absolument aucune ambiguïté oui
je pense que c'est dans une grande
démocratie on doit manifester le
principe du respect du droit
quand on contrôle les financements je le
répète il est pas interdit il est juste
déclaratives et on doit dire tous
viennent les sommes arrivant de
l'étranger
qu'est-ce que je pense alors là j'ai
adoré votre quatrième question qu'est ce
que je pense du respect du contrat
d'engagement républicain qui sera exigée
de toutes les associations soliste en
l'octroi ou bénéficiant d'une subvention
publique sourire je serais à votre place
j'irai beaucoup plus loin je pense qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de recevoir des
subventions de l'état pour être obligé
de proclamer son engagement républicain
ce comme si vous vous dites je reçois
pas d'argent de l'état je peux dire tout
ce que je veux je peux déclarer ma haine
de quiconque
je trouve inadmissible qu'on ce qu'on
refuse de signer un engagement
républicain comme si c'était quelque
chose qui obérait notre liberté mais qui
peut s'inscrire dans l'espace
républicain sans dire j'adhère aux
principes républicains donc moi je ne
voudrais pas qu'on limite cela cet
engagement aux seules associations
recevant des subventions
je voudrais qu'on lui tende à tout le
monde chaque association en france pour
être déclarée devrait s'engager
évidemment un respecté de manière
intégrale est totale les principes
républicains
oumarou
quelle appréciation je porte sur le
régime de 10 cl solution administrative
de la station issu de la loi de 36 et
c'est moi j'estime que il ya dans tout
système est aujourd'hui plus que dans
n'importe quelle époque du monde
le principe qu'on appelle la
comptabilité dans les entreprises c'est
à dire le principe de rendre des comptes
est au coeur de l'engagement citoyen on
ne peut pas faire les choses aujourd'hui
sans rendre des comptes
autant dire voilà ce qu'on a fait et je
puis vous dire que en gros ce qu'on a
appelé le principe pour empêcher les
poutres comme ça qu'ils étaient appelés
par la presse le principe anti putsch
mais vous n'avez pas idée du niveau de
démocratie dans les institutions juives
qui dit niveau démocratie dit parfois
joutes électorales
mais à la fin si ça va pas cesser déféré
devant un tribunal qui tranche
mais il y à des renouvellements il ya
des lilas des assemblées générales il y
a rapport moral il y a des rapports
financiers bref cette idée de rendre des
comptes implique que si les choses ne
sont pas claires et bien l'état doit
sanctionner comme n'importe quelle
association et c'est la garantie
finalement du bon fonctionnement des
cultes leur insertion parfaite dans une
forme d'espérance républicaine écoutez
faites moi confiance jamais j'ai vu au
secours catholique et je peux le dire
aussi pour genève j'avais je n'ai vu à
l'oser au casino jasor ou dans les
caisses de secours protestante ou
musulmane jamais je n'ai vu qu'on
demande un certificat de baptême à
quelqu'un pour l'aider
c'est à dire que le législateur qui est
parfaitement informée de ce
fonctionnement le sait tellement bien et
je lui vends des spécialistes du budget
que lorsque vous faites un don pour une
association cultuelle votre don
défiscalisé à hauteur de 66 % vous
croyez quand même pas que c'est pour les
beaux yeux du rabbin du pasteur du prêt
de l'imam de qui vous voulez c'est
uniquement parce que l'état a
parfaitement conscience qu'une partie de
cet argent est consacré aux biens
publics au bien commun
donc la même façon que l'état en
défiscalisant les dons considère que
vous apportez quelque chose pour tous si
vous avez un comportement qui est pas
cohérent avec le bien commun il est
légitime que l'état fonctionne et que
l'état procède la dissolution ou
organisation des instances dirigeantes
des associations estimez vous adapter
les mesures qui touchent à la police des
cultes oui oui parce que ça ne touche
pas la police des cultes j'ai un exemple
simple on a dit c'est inadmissible on va
nous imposer des changements on va nous
imposer les pentes l'égalité entre les
sexes dans les associations
moi je suis pour les instances
dirigeantes des associant qu'ils ont des
instances républicaines
le consistoire illinois 1905 mais il ya
des femmes présentes communauté lorsque
j'ai été élu dans mes fonctions
la première visite que j'ai voulu faire
un chabbat surpasser tout un week-end
dans une communauté j'ai choisi
volontairement en le disant bien une
communauté présidée par une femme pour
dire il faut que les femmes s'engagent
dans les instances communautaires et
c'est formidable
de là à ce qu'on me dise que on m'oblige
à faire en sorte que dans les synagogues
les hommes et les femmes sont séparés
comme le son comme c'était le cas dans
les églises notamment pays basque pour
je passais à quelqu'un du pays basque
ici mais à saint jean de luz le
magnifique église sur la différence
entre les églises du pays basque c'est
que ce sont les hommes qui sont en haut
les fermes en bas dans les synagogues
c'est souvent les femmes enrôlées âmes
en bas mais au-delà de cette petite
différence géographique
il n'empêche que jamais dans la loi je
n'ai vu quelque chose qui pourrait
laisser penser que dans la gestion du
culte aum imposerait de dire ou de
penser ou de faire quelque chose
contraire à la règle que je pense être
celle de la de la religion juive
en revanche dans le système associatif
oui on doit respecter absolument
l'intégralité de leur week-end et
notamment sur cet enjeu homme femme qui
me paraît être un enjeu très important
la notion des mises de culte vous
parait-elle suffisant défini oui elle
est définie en réalité par le fait qu'il
ya une communauté quelle qu'elle soit
qui accepte une personne comme son
dirigeant cultuelle la réalité c'est que
dans notre système un peu au consistoire
les communautés peuvent choisir un bain
elle doit juste le soumettre à mon
approbation sauf quelques grosses
communautés où il ya un système
électoral un peu plus poussé mais
globalement si une communauté accepte
quelqu'un comme son dirigeant ou
cultuelles à ce moment-là il y là il est
adoubé d'une certaine manière par la
communauté mais il peut pas sortir d'un
système parce que malgré tout il est
encadré par un président ou une
présidente des administrateurs bref un
système associatif qui est aussi un
responsable de ce qu'il fait c'est l'un
des des points que je dois juste
souligné attention en france mais c'est
logique c'est le mouvement
la société qui le fait à ne pas
considérer que le principe qui
fonctionne dans l'église catholique est
le même qui fonctionne dans tous les
cultes la hérarchie n'est pas exactement
la même le système pyramidal n'est pas
exactement le même
nous avons la chance d'en juger zoom
français d'avoir un système issu de
napoléon c'est à dire un système
pyramidal avec un grand vin de france
des rabbins régionaux et des rabbins
locaux mais c'est pas le cas partout et
d'autres associations ont pu se créer
enfin le projet de loi prévoit
d'harmoniser législation applicable
encadrant les cultes et notamment pour
les as moselle je suis toujours prudent
dès qu'on veut toucher la spécificité de
l'alsace et la moselle
parce que c'est parfois oublier notre
histoire et notre histoire nous a
structuré sais pas ce qui va mettre en
péril les ni le budget de l'état ni le
fonctionnement je trouve qu'il ya un bon
équilibre et il ya une entente entre
tous en alsace en moselle qui fait chaud
au coeur et qui donne finalement à
penser que c'est dans la diversité des
systèmes parce que si on commence à
toucher en alsace en moselle
on va commencer à vouloir toucher aussi
outre-mer et si outre-mer dans quel
outre-mer c'est pas la même chose à la
réunion que à mayotte et après on verra
bref on c'est un débat sans fin je crois
que là ici il s'agit de réaffirmer les
choses essentielles pour nous comment on
va construire quelque chose ensemble je
voudrais si vous permettez avant
d'entamer le temps de débat le sous
traitant
vous proposer quelque chose si on en est
à infirmer les principes essentiels les
principes républicains
ma seule crainte si vous restez que
finalement on présente cela comme un
fait simple les religions sont un risque
pour l'état
on va les encadrer pour empêcher qu'elle
soit un risque pour l'état
or ce n'est pas le cas on sait très bien
aucun culte ne demande ni la suppression
de la laïcité aucun et surtout pas nous
sommes profondément laïque est
profondément attaché à la laïcité c'est
la laïcité qui nous permet de dialoguer
entre nous il sent la laïcité la
cérémonie oui prophétique dont je vous
parlais alors entre l'église et nous ne
peut pas elle peut pas parce que ya
aucune raison si on se pense plus proche
de ce qui est consubstantiellement
l'état donc une raison de discuter avec
des gens qu'on l'accueille en tribu pas
cette qualité
alors si c'est le cas peut-être que dans
l'article 1 de cette loi tron devrait
rappeler le principe de liberté de
pratique religieuse qui est au coeur de
ce qu'est la laïcité
oui neutralité de l'état mais avant tout
la liberté de pratique religieuse parce
que ce que je sens parfois chez certains
et notamment pour celles et ceux qui
sont dans des collectivités
territoriales parfois je me sens
l'interprétation est un exemple la caf
d'un département de banlieue parisienne
qui par exemple va refuser les bons de
vacances pour des enfants des familles
qui mettent leurs enfants chez les
scouts ce coup de juifs en l'occurrence
mais s'appelle des scouts catholiques ce
que tu ne lis pas ce que vous voulez
mais ce culte musulman elle est s'est
pas masqué à ce qu'on appellerait dans
l'école un caractère propre qu'on peut
pour autant nier le côté bien commun que
peuvent apporter ces collines vacances
qui sont parfois les seule façon de
partir en vacances pour des enfants
moi je quand j'étais petit on partait
aurait pas les moyens d'aller en colo
joue jamais un clou je les ai rêvé vf
quand les gens disent ou le vvf vacances
de pauvres mais ces vacances qui étaient
mes vacances et donc dire à quelqu'un
parce qu'on est dans une interprétation
pas rigoriste une partie sont fausses
fallacieuses du terme laïcité et qu'on
en vient en réalité à décrire ce qui
serait un état athée
ce que nous ne sommes pas nous sommes un
état laïque pas athée et bien je crois
qu'il ya un véritable risque et si j'ose
m'adresser à vous tous mais en visant
l'un d'entre vous qui a eu d'éminentes
fonctions au ministère de la défense et
la république n'a qu'à s'en féliciter ce
ministre arrivant en fonction ces thèmes
et je ne veux pas dire lequel d'entre
vous mais c'était en 1997 si j'ai bonne
mémoire ou quelqu'un non je ne veux
absolument pas donner son nom
publiquement et ce ministre à une idée
vent lui présente plein de mesures de
réductions de coûts et on lui dit les
houblonniers ça coûte cher
comme cinq ministres plutôt futé il dit
on va demander au contrôle général des
armées de faire une inspection il
mandate donc ce ministre très avisé un
certain monsieur alix contrôleur général
des armées de son état et ce brave homme
fait un audit des aumôneries des armées
voilà sa conclusion 1
ils font un travail formidable 2 ils ne
sont pas assez bien soutenu il faut
mieux les soutenir mieux les aider 3 on
a véritablement besoin de ce qu'ils font
parce qu'en terme de liant social
ils sont extraordinaires et moi je
voudrais conclure là dessus en vous
disant que si on est capable dé
réaffirmé le principe de liberté de
pratique religieuse ce qui lève
l'hypothèque que certains verraient dans
ce texte entend lui il s'agit encore de
coincer les religions qui sont
fondamentalement contre la république ce
qu'il faut eh bien on aurait
premièrement cela deuxièmement on aurait
une façon de dire il nous faut
absolument que les associations le tissu
associatif tiennent le terrain c'est
parce que le tissu associatif a été
brimé dans cette capacité à servir à
accompagner les gens que les personnes
en difficulté on est obligé de faire du
soutien scolaire dans des associations
mal foutu des à 100 qu'ils avaient des
objectifs cachés et qui sous prétexte de
soutien scolaire ou sous prétexte de
donner un goûter aux enfants
en réalité les endoctriner les coupes de
leur famille les coupes de la société
les coupes de la république et donc il
faut impérativement redonner de la
vitalité à ce tissu social que moi j'ai
pu connaître dans la jeunesse peut-être
les mjc
m tout ce tissu qui était la réalité
parce qu'en réalité dès que vous avez
des agents qui sont des agents de
liaison de liens de création de lien
social
ce que sont aussi les religions avec
d'autres évidemment
eh bien vous produisez plus d'espérance
peut-être plus de voiliers plus
d'espérance aussi républicaine
voilà merci de m'avoir entendu merci
beaucoup alors j'ai plusieurs demandes
de parole troie en l'occurrence madame
goulet je suis là mal se passer pour moi
donc j'ai pas prendre de trop longtemps
que je dis que c'est important que tout
le monde participe
merci pour vos propos parce qu'on a
besoin d'entendre aussi ça c'est à dire
que vous avez parlé tout début de votre
intervention de ce pour quoi nous étions
là et il faut pas l'oublier
vous avez rappelé les attentats vous
avez rappelé à mais pâtit vous avez
rappelé et et voilà cet antisémitisme
grandissant dans notre pays qui est une
réalité dans les banlieues c'est un vrai
problème sont quand même le reconnaître
puisque tous les enfants juifs ont
pratiquement tous quitté l'école de la
république
il faut le reconnaître aussi donc voilà
et c'est ensemble que nous arriverons à
combattre tous ces fléaux de la société
alors je suis assez rassuré par vos
propos parce que globalement ce texte
vous convient globalement parce que je
pense voilà vous avez répondu à nos
questions et est globalement vous vous
sentez pas entre guillemets menacés dans
votre foi et dans votre croyance par ce
texte et c'est important pour nous parce
qu'effectivement vous avez rappelé que
la liberté religieuse est nécessaire la
liberté de croyance c'est une liberté
que chacun effectivement a le droit de
poser aujourd'hui j'aurais envie de dire
que ce tissu social dont vous avez parlé
est une vraie nécessité
effectivement il est probablement il a
promis ont été cassées ou en tout cas et
c'est diffusé un petit peu différemment
parce que nous avons aussi pas été très
attentif à notre politique de peuplement
souvent souvent c'est une des
conséquences
il me semble voilà
donc vraiment moi je voudrais vous
demander c'est bon voilà c'est important
vous l'avez dit mais honnêtement
aujourd'hui vous vous sentez pas menacé
par ce texte j'aimerais vous l'entendre
dire parce que parfois on l'entends et
je pense que c'est important pour nous
que nous l'entendions et je voulais vous
remercier pour voilà la clarté de vos
prouve en tout cas cette république qui
qui aujourd'hui nous permet de vivre
ensemble vous l'avait conforté par mes
propos merci à vous merci ça ça vaut pas
beaucoup mais sur président oui merci
messieurs je crois rabin alors moi j'ai
aussi bien entendu que ce texte avait
été concertée en amont avec les cultes
et je pense que c'est important que cela
soit précisée j'ai deux questions de la
première vous parlez d'élargir 1905 à un
objet social en parlant par exemple du
secours catholique ou mais est ce que ce
ne serait pas justement le résultat
inverse de celui qu'on cherche à obtenir
en séparant bien le cultuel du culturel
parce qu'on sait aussi que le politique
et notamment l'islam politique arrive
souvent par le culturel pour ensuite
comment s'installer dans le cultuel donc
cette séparation me semble-t-il entre
1905 et 1901 est la base même de lutter
contre ce qui permettrait de développer
l'islamisme et c'est en ça d'ailleurs
que je réponds a fini bas en 15 ans que
je pense que c'est vraiment sur la
structure même qu'il faut jouer et donc
je crois pas qu'on puisse lutter contre
l'islamisme en tant que tel comme on
lutterait contre le nazisme sans
s'interroger vraiment sur la
structuration même de la religion qui
est l'islam
donc voilà première question et ensuite
est ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
comment justement sont désignés les
rabbins puisque vous avez effectivement
une si une organisation qui est
différente comme vous le disiez de
l'église catholique
merci vraiment pour ces deux questions
en 2000 je peux vous redire oui il faut
faire cette loi cette gloire est
nécessaire juste peut-être je veux pas
dire mais escapade mais c'est que dans
la volonté de traiter des dérives
inacceptables de certains on risque
parfois de toucher des associations et
des systèmes religieux qui ont été
vertueux
depuis leur création je suis sidéré de
devoir vous êtes pudeurs de jeune fils
certains signent un texte pour les
valeurs républicaines enfin je jeu c'est
ce qu'ont répondu mais mes prédécesseurs
et mon éminent prédécesseur david seeds
i'm lorsque le lorsque en prend un
napoléon lui demande ce que vous
défendrez la france compte si elle était
attaquée il avait répondu oui jusqu'à la
mort la question ne se pose même pas
mais si elle se pose alors il faut la
poser c'est le principe et je crois sur
le ce principe là on nous sommes prêts
non pas faire des sacrifices nous sommes
prêts à accepter je vous le dis moi un
contrôle préfectoral ne me gêne
absolument pas un contrôle de l'état
travaille en confiance j'ai beaucoup
moins confiance actuellement dans
l'interprétation que certains pourraient
faire donc moi je me dis cette loi en
réaffirmant des principes républicains
pourraient aussi réaffirmé que nous
sommes dans une république laïque c'est
à dire avec des caractères propres pour
chacun possible et pas dans une
république
athée qui fait qu'aujourd'hui au jour
d'aujourd'hui par exemple on va croire
que je vise un seul département
mais par exemple est un département ou
une municipalité qui livrer des colis
pour encore créer du lien social qui n'a
pas de repas possible pour les personnes
âgées a lancé un appel de marché sur cet
appel de marché la demande et des colis
cacher hvala pour les musulmans et les
juifs et la préfecture se poser des
questions savoir ce qu'on attaque ou pas
cette décision parce que heureusement le
préfet a eu l'intelligence de considérer
que ça pour avoir des colis cacher et
vous me dans l'appel d'offres m cacher
parce que si vous mettez une périphrase
ridicule oui des fois il faut faire
simple je crois que réaffirmer les
choses importantes
c'est bien parfois dans la vie c'est
comme ça à vous savez dans la vie
si on fait les anniversaires de mariage
si on s'élève tout cela c'est aussi pour
dire des choses qui me paraissent
évidentes et c'est bien de le dire
parfois
quant à la concertation en amont oui
elle était important je vous assure
qu'elle était importante et c'est est
inclus dans le puits ce qu'on a vu les
projets évolué donc ça a été le cas
maintenant
il pourrait y avoir une
instrumentalisation de ce mouvement du
social tout ce qui est social dans la
loi 1905
mais dans les faits on crée d'autres
associations pour porter cette activité
donc c'est moi je préfère avoir une
homogénéité du système en disant à
donner à ceux qui ont besoin c'est aussi
s'occuper celles et ceux qui à un moment
sont en difficulté et on peut pas
considérer que notre seule façon d'aider
les gens c'est de prier pour eux si
j'osais ici après avoir cité la bible
permettez moi de citer bernard de
clairvaux qui disait la plus belle des
prières sera l'oeuvre de vos mains donc
parfois donner aux pauvres
c'est peut-être mieux qu'une prière donc
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer que
donner aux pauvres soit aussi acceptable
dans une association cultuelle je sais
que certains s'échinent à mettre dans la
loi 1905 la gestion d'immeubles savait
qu'on nous donne déjà des immeubles des
legs on verra après les mois ci vous
verrez vous pouvez le donner au
consistoire ça sera très volontiers
comme moi j'en ai pas donc je sais pas
gérer un truc théorique ces cinq
questions de richesse encore quand on
rame à votre question est essentielle
il ya la norme en fait nous avons la
chance d'avoir une école ras minik un
pas en france un pari elle était à metz
elle a quitté la moselle pour
s'installer à paris
elle forme les rames un français
certains postes sont obligatoires pour
ces rabbins et puis si on manque de
personnel rabbinique dans telle ou telle
communauté
on peut faire appel à des personnes qui
ont les compétences en avoir forcément
la reconnaissance académique qu'on
valide rétroactivement nous par une
commission est de toute manière aucune
association du consistoire ne peut
nommer un ravin
s'il n'est pas validé par votre
serviteur en fait j'élargis cette
responsabilité au consistoire
puisqu'avec le président mergui le
président du consistoire central ou
sinon la france et on connaît toutes les
communautés et on sait à peu près des
besoins des uns des autres donc c'est
toujours un échange entre les
communautés locales et les instances
nationales du consistoire
mais globalement il ne peut pas y avoir
un rabbin au tout désigné parce que de
toute manière il s'insère ray dans un
une institution administrative
répondants probablement à la loi 1901
parce que c'est 1905 a aucune
possibilité
ça dépend de nous donc imaginons
quelqu'un qui va je suis pas moi une
ville et joue il crée sa petite
synagogue ce qui peut arriver parfois ce
qui crée parfois derrière des tensions
locales
mais globalement on arrive à imposer une
sorte de yalta des rames à merci ensuite
ce sera madame benbassa puis monsieur
kader messieurs c'est sûr on va
commencer par quatre oui mais seulement
merci beaucoup pour cette cette audition
rappelant à la prière de tous les
samedis pour la république française
dans toutes les synagogues c'est quand
même aussi un signe un signe important
et pour qu'elle vive dans la concorde
on a ici un texte qui à mon avis
beaucoup de vertus moi je voudrais vous
poser plusieurs questions la première
c'est sur les revenus
[Musique]
notamment éventuellement étrangers que
vous recevez vous avez parlé des
immeubles où je considère que
effectivement d'abord il faut en donner
à vendre avant de les gérer je vois bien
la mécanique
et puis aussi les phrases à nîmes qui
viendraient de l'étranger
comment est-ce que puisque puisqu'on à
cette dialectique pour les autres ports
et au moins une autre religion c'est
important qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
faire la comparaison avec avec
évidemment
le judaïsme donc question de avec ce but
singer nous avait expliqué dans une
autre audition d'une autre mission
d'information que la filière casher
représentait environ 30% des revenus du
consistoire
est ce que vous pourriez nous confirmer
ce chiffre ou le faire vérifier voir si
si ce chiffre a évolué parce que c'est
effectivement aussi très important pour
le financement notamment l'islam en
france merci beaucoup
est-ce que vous m'entendez est-ce que
vous m'entendez pas très bien merci
merci monsieur le grand rabbin pour
votre intervention claire et synthétique
je voudrais d'abord dire quelques mots
sur la la première membre de madame
boulet à savoir traduire cette phrase de
loyauté à la république s'est dit la
maille quotas dina à savoir la loi de
ton royaume la loi du royaume et aloi
donc c'est cette loyauté qui termine les
prières dans le judaïsme
monsieur le grand rabbin vous avez parlé
du judaïsme traditionnel que vous
représentez mais vous n'avez pas parlé
aussi de la composante réformer libéral
les du judaïsme comme vous le savez
mieux que moi les assauts de 1905 est le
culte juif s'est regroupée sous forme
d'association dans l'union des
associations cultuelles israélites de
france et d'algérie à l'époque l'algérie
est en langue française
bonds est le consistoire et une
association cultuelle qui étaient là dès
1905 désigner le conseil
d'administration de chaque association
cultuelle
donc vous avez elle décrit
le la désignation des rabbins et oui
c'est s'ils vont à l'école rabbinique
d'ailleurs on peut se demander si ce
modèle qui a été clé en 1829 puisque
l'école centrale a d'unique de metz a
été créé en 1829 à mèze et elle a
déménagé à paris en 1883 c'est vrai je
l'appelle un élément c'est que les
rabbins au 19e siècle
aller à cette école est en même temps
pour avoir un enseignement laïc
objectifs et disons plus ils ont une pas
de la théologie mais un l'enseignement
des religions
il faisait un diplôme à l'école pratique
des hautes études qui se trouvent encore
à la sombre alors ça pourrait servir
comme modèle pour la formation des imams
aujourd'hui bien sûr est les élèves
ravin de l'école ne viennent plus à la
sorbonne
c'est cette information ces
constitutions cultuelle du culte juive a
permis n'est ce pas le pluralisme
religieux
par conséquent il ya eu très rapidement
est la formation cultuel et du judaïsme
libéral les ravages du judaïsme libéral
il ya quand même plusieurs femmes en
général sont formés à l'étranger à
savoir l'angleterre aux états unis ou à
miss rails et ces personnes ne passent
pas par la voie 1 consistoriale alors il
faut rappeler qu'il y à de très
nombreuses synagogue libérale et qui qui
sont eux qui s'adresse à des personnes
qui ont leurs pratiques cultuelles qui
est dit un peu différente du
du judaïsme traditionnel que le
consistoire représente alors aujourd'hui
on peut poser voilà je finirai avec sa
largeur de savoir quelle sera
l'influencé ou les conséquences de cette
nouvelle loi
aussi bien sur le judaïsme traditionnel
que le judaïsme libéral est ce que il y
aura dix ont des changements qui se
feront je n'en sais rien est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir quelques éléments sur les
répercussions de ces voix sur plus
cultes les chutes
non merci madame benbassa monsieur k
nerfs excusez moi j'étais un peu surpris
par
c'est pour ça que j'ai forcé la voix je
voulais je voulais mais je vous promets
que je sors pas de la séance monsieur
bride
je voulais aussi remercier bien sûr avec
la fia pour son intervention empreinte
des lumières de la révolution des
décisions de l' empire et de l'humour de
pierre dac
ce qui fait un ensemble intéressant en
la matière mais mme goulet a rappelé la
prière la public du samedi matin à
l'office de de shabbat et c'est ça
montre tout de l'attachement bien sûr
nos principes républicains porté par la
communauté et enfin les communautés
juives de france sans consistoire
central il faut le rappeler aussi qu'ils
nomment qui vous nomme monsieur le grand
rabbin c'est donc un organe laïque qui
nomme le l'autorité cultuelle donc
hilarante de l'unité des communautés
vous avez évoqué et je vous en remercie
dans vos conclusions et dans vos
propositions l'idée que finalement
organisé de manière régalienne
les religions étaient le signe d'une
république forte mais qu'il fallait
aussi qu'elle soit bienveillante pour
éviter justement les dérives et en tant
qu'ancien ministre de la ville il est
vrai que j'ai vu le dégâts des
prédateurs mais s'il ya des prédateurs
dans les quartiers c'est qu'il ya des
proies et les trois sont issus d'un
terreau social qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il est notamment
dans dans ces quartiers que nous
connaissons bien pour beaucoup d'entre
nous vous avez évoqué donc l'antidote
finalement de la réponse sociale qui
n'existe pas dans ce texte et je voulais
simplement savoir si vous estimiez que
ce texte ne pouvait prospérer que s'il y
avait aussi cette dimension sociale à
mettre à mettre en oeuvre qui est
annoncé par le gouvernement dans un
délai qui n'est pas aujourd'hui
identifiées et surtout sur un contenu
qui ne peut pas faire uniquement l'objet
de d'information et d'annoncés
concernant des tel ou tel milliards sur
sur le terrain je pense qu'il faut une
grande politique pour éviter
effectivement ces dérives locale un
dernier mot sur l'unité de la communauté
sur l'attachement à la république je
voulais vous interroger sans aucune
agressivité vous l'imaginez bien de ma
part sur finalement les tendances
communautariste qui existent aussi dans
la religion juive et en particulier je
pense au développement de la communauté
loubavitch
dans beaucoup de nos villes qui certes
bien évidemment est très respectueuse
des principes de la république mais
peut-être avec un renfermement sur sur
elle même qui peut poser interrogations
aux citoyens qui peut les côtoyer je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment en
l'espèce
vous avez la parole puis ensuite on
prend la 3 autres questions merci m
la sénatrice pendant d'avoir rappelé la
prière pour a vu que je voulais pas le
faire parce que comme je m'échine a
supplié les autres cultes ans parce que
l'islam est le faire réciter dans leur
mosquée mais dans tous les deux cultes
très régulièrement comme nous le faisons
les sinagots que je voulais pas la
couverture nous d'une certaine manière
mais je crois que si dans le moment le
plus sacré du culte toutes les religions
en france on est capable de redire que
notre ambition notre rêve c'est de vivre
ensemble avec nos concitoyens parce que
on peut réparer imaginer tout ça que le
principe même du communautarisme je
réponds tout petit peu la vence la
question du ministre enfin de scaer mais
c'est c'est impossible de concevoir le
communautarisme dans le judaïsme parce
que jérémy déjà jérémy le prophète
jérémie disait au peuple prier pour la
paix du royaume dans lequel vous êtes
parce que de saper des pentes ap donc
même s'il y avait et imaginons ce qui
n'est pas le cas
qui dit quelque part à un moment une
tentation de se dire on veut juste vivre
bien pour vivre bien faut que tout le
monde soit bien c'est que c'est le
principe dans les mariages juifs par
exemple de briser le vert au nom du
mariage au moment du mariage on estime
en général c'est pas prouvée mais en
général que au moins les les mariés sont
heureux au moins à ce moment là c'est ça
reste à prouver de manière scientifique
mais normalement c'est la norme
eh bien on leur demande à ce moment-là
de briser un verre pour que
symboliquement ils se disent 'nous
savons malgré notre bonheur qu'il ya du
malheur dans le monde et c'est parce que
nous sommes heureux que nous avons
l'obligation d'essayer d'un stylet du
bonheur dans le monde alors
symboliquement c'est aussi à des
cessions du temps de josaine ça veut
dire qu' aucun bonheur des complets s'il
n'est pas parti
et très largement vous avez raison cette
prière est essentiel parce que chaque
fois qu'on l'entend dans les synagogues
nous sommes dans une logique à dans une
logique qui nous pousse à dire qu'est ce
que je peux faire pour la république
comment je peux au quotidien et j'ai
transformé cette prière d'air en y
insérant vins propose à mon prédécesseur
d'y insérer un passage pour les soldats
français après les attaques d'ouzbine on
avait perdu dix soldats
je suis dit il faut qu'on convaincu
l'armée dans cette prière
et puis quand on a vu le déploiement des
forces de l'ordre et le risque prenez le
policier après les attentats notamment
les policiers morts charlie avec le
front guen solaro et à mettre berrabeh
et la policière à montrouge lendemain
j'ai dit il faut qu'on inclut aussi les
forces de l'ordre et s'est fait dans la
prière pour la pluie
donc oui vous avez raison c'est
essentiel les revenus l'étranger il y en
a partout la balance est plutôt nous qui
est don mais si elle est revenue ce ne
peut être que de fondations par un
américaines anglaises suisse
mais tout est déclarée de toute manière
donc la question de la déclaration ne
nous gêne pas et je ne vois pas qui cela
peut gêner en honnêteté en toute
honnêteté
sauf à trouver que les fonds sont
étonnants donc moi je pense qu aucun
problème à voir ça pour ce que vous
appelez les trois années c'est à dire
tout le personnel qui n'est pas
rabbinique il peut arriver qu'ils aient
des gens qui arrivent alors ministre est
en général sont des francophones
souvent d'ailleurs des gens qui sont
partis en israël s'installer et qui
reviennent maintenant servir les
communautés de ce manière il y a des
garde-fous à la tentation éventuelle du
discours - républicain que les
consubstantiel dans le consistoire
ce sont les associations et les fidèles
dire que un rasage nous hein
alors s'il a une très belle voix on lui
passe beaucoup de choses mais
un razan quelqu'un personnel
communautaire qui auraient des propos
déplacés qui sont pas en cohérence avec
la politique du consistoire et le fait
que nous sommes profondément français se
verrait révoqué dans les quinze secondes
par n'importe laquelle des asociaux
consistoriale libéral réformer ma sortie
20 tout ce que vous voulez mais vous
avez raison de lire sur les revenus
cacher c'est une très très très bonne et
très important de questions parce que
bon c'est légèrement en baisse à cause
les difficultés
sur marché cacher sur le fait qu'il ya
des opérateurs qui abattent à l'étranger
et qui à cause des désaccords avec les
pays de schengen c'est un peu compliqué
d'empêcher la viande avec l'étranger
surtout dans l'espace schengen d'entrées
en france
mais globalement c'est de l'ordre de 30%
je vous rassure les musulmans sont en
contact étroit avec nos responsables de
l'abattage rituel pour à la fois fort
mais nous formons les abatteurs rituel
le nous et donc en tout cas à se former
notamment sur le bien-être animal et sur
les normes d'hygiène et puis sur une
répartition équitable des droits de
battage qui permettrait effectivement de
sécuriser les financements de nos temps
du csm
je vous le dire mais ça ça me concerne
pas directement mais j'étais stupéfait
quand mes amis du csm m'ont dit que leur
budget global c'est trente mille euros
par an pendant qu'ils son besoin de
sources de financement pour répondre à
sénatrice madame benbassa oui vous avez
raison de rappeler que la loi
à force de loi dans tout ce qui est
économique est juste mais c'est parce
que vous êtes une historienne je me
permets juste de vous dire que je crois
mais j'en suis certain fait que l'école
rabbinique et à migrer de metz à paris
en 1859
c'est lié à un phénomène historique très
précise que j'arrive elle daté et pas 89
mais ça son importance parce que hélas
important que vous rappeliez à la fois
l'école rabbinique qui bouge et dîna des
marques contadina la vocation des
rabbins forme à l'école rabbinique et
j'ai retrouvé les textes qu'on regarde
le livre sur l'histoire l'école
rabbinique est un livre du rabbin c'est
le rabbin bauer qui écrit l'histoire de
l'école rabbinique de sa fondation
jusqu'en 1930
il explique que la vocation des rabbins
était d'apprendre un par les français
dans leur communauté
interdit les discours en en fait c'était
pas de
mich lui dis-je c'est une langue en fait
le polonais en fait c'était le patois
alsacien en particulier l'interdiction
discours ange duo espagnol bref les
discours devait se faire en français et
donc je date très précisément ce moment
où le construire s'engage comme
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je vous
dise 159 parce qu'en 1860 l'alliance
israélite universelle se fondent et va
enseigner l'amour de la france le
français à des générations de jeunes
partout dans le pays
enfin au maroc le français en algérie
elle le français puisque c'est suite à
la sphère de damas c'est pour ça que la
date de manière très précise et donc
l'idée c'est nos rabbins ont vocation à
rattacher la la communauté à l'amour et
la conception très française du judaïsme
ça donnera quelques anicroches en
algérie parce que quand les jeunes
rabbin frais émoulu de l'école
rabbinique de la rue vauquelin arrive et
en algérie et il y avait parfois un
décalage avec les maîtres anciens voilà
mais in fine et ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné
et ça fonctionne toujours bien sûr le
judaïsme réformé
oui évidemment le rabbin ne passe pas
par l'école rabbinique mais ce sont
aussi des associant très républicaine on
a des échanges avec ses associations
avec les rabbins et je puis vous
garantir et vous assurez de leur
parfaite cohérence avec les impératifs
républicains qui sont ceux définis ou à
raison par dina des marques contadina la
loi de l'état à force de loi est
globalement et qu'ils voulaient que ce
soir
dans tout l'espagne de l'échiquier que
ce soit la réforme pour anticiper pour
la réponse pour se cacher pour le
mouvement loubavitch que vous avez cités
il n'y a absolument aucune pulsion
communautariste et pour les loubavitchs
dont on peut parfois discutée le côté
très allants disons être très
missionnaire ils ont une tradition que
je trouve formidable c'est de prendre un
psaume et de le chanter avec l'air de la
marseillaise ce qui est assez émouvant
quand les entend chanter ça une sorte de
rencontre entre l'espérance et
républicaine la marseillaise et
l'espérance des psaumes
mais je reviens au coeur de votre
question oui la dimension sociale et est
essentiel réaffirmé des choses et ne pas
mettre les moyens de proposer autre
chose c'est souvent ce qui nous manque
je veux dire la lutte contre le
radicalisme par exemple c'est aussi
proposer un contre-discours y compris
sur internet on parle des dérives mais
des rivales débutent souvent sur
internet il faut qu'on soit capable de
produire quelque chose là pourquoi moi
je je disais je suis beaucoup plus pour
quelque chose mais le pur il faut le
nourrir
donc au niveau social il faut qu'on soit
capable de dire il ya un travail qui est
fait par certains mais il est biaisé il
est salie littéralement par un but caché
qui est de recruter des gens et de se
détourner de ce qu'est l'espérance
républicaine et donc il faut qu'on mette
en place un tissu social conques on
irrigue à nouveau des associations par
des fonds qu on donne très rapidement je
crois que le gouvernement parlait de 1
milliard pour la politique de la ville
dans le plan de relance c'est quelque
chose qui me semble être vital parce que
tout ce travail de proximité qui étaient
faits a été abandonnée et la nature
ayant horreur du vide
et bien certains se sont engouffrés dans
cette faille mais je crois que il faut
collectivement qu'on sent capable de de
trouver les moyens de répondre à cette
attente ces besoins de tenter tant de
personnes celles et ceux qui finalement
n'ont que la république pour s'occuper
d'eux bien merci alors d'autres
questions je rappelle que le temps nous
est un peu serré
madame de la gontrie puis ensuite
monsieur hervé monsieur est monsieur
richard tu m'aimes de la gontrie vous
avez la parole
le risque est encore là oui beaucoup
nous vous entendons bien merci beaucoup
je salue évidemment fait une korcia mais
son programme hattrick parce que depuis
le début des interventions
nous avons bien noté que par rapport à
ce texte qui nous occupe
je résume et il ne voit pas de
difficultés sur le contrat d'engagement
républicain et effectivement les rappels
de certains et de plusieurs la prière
pour la république française converge
vers cet cette attente pas de difficulté
pour le contrôle des flux financiers
même si on a identifié avec son humour
habituel que c'était entre guillemets un
problème de riche la particularité de la
nomination des rabbins et le besoin de
soutien social et c'était notre dernière
intervention très intéressant alors du
coup si je dis que votre intervention m
yg c'est que ce nous allons d'ores et
déjà rencontré représentants des cultes
sont en revanche plutôt hostile
en tout cas très inquiet de ce texte
comment expliquez vous cette différence
d'appréciation est ce dû à
l'organisation à votre propre
organisation qui fait que ce mode de
comment dire de régulation le terme
n'est pas heureux a permis de d'éviter
les dérives qui nous préoccupe c'est ça
m'intéresserait de
de savoir ce que vous imaginez pertinent
puisque incontestablement il ya d'un
côté une inquiétude face ne racontons
pas d'histoires face au culte musulman
et à la dérive de certains et d'un autre
côté une inquiétude des religions mais
j'ai bien compris que ce n'était pas la
vôtre sur les effets collatéraux du
texte qui nous est opposé
merci madame monsieur lui qui avait
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
grand rabbin dans la prolongation de ce
que vient de dire marie pierre de la
gontrie je trouve que dans votre propos
vous c'est qu'il est intéressant que
vous y insister sur le fait que beaucoup
de croyants beaucoup de personnes qui
pratiquent une religion dans notre pays
sont authentiques républicaine qu'un
moment dans leur pratique elle quelle
qu'elle soit ils le remettent en cause
cela n'est d'ailleurs dont l'essentiel
des religions historiquement installé
dans notre pays et l'islam étant une une
autre question bien sûr la question de
la prière notamment pour la république
le dal homme seul le dominer ça va me
fac et gal yam devenu république a par
la suite est qui et qui résister à rome
chaque année ces deux vies procès de
cette même logique et oui c'était bien
que nathalie goulet le le le rappelle
donc moi je trouve que vous même si vous
n'êtes peut-être plus allants que
certains de vos prédécesseurs
représentant les cultes sur ce texte
vous avez quand même manifester cette
importante de 2 rappeler cela et moi je
trouve que votre proposition que de
rappeler dans l'article 1er la notion de
liberté de religieux religieuses et
liberté de culte
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour moi et dans la liberté de deux
religieuses
il n'y a pas que la liberté de
conviction ou la liberté d'avoir une
fois mais la capacité de la pratiquer et
j'en reviens à l'article
10 de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nul ne doit être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestation ne trouble pas l'ordre
public établi par la loi
donc on a bien ces deux éléments là la
fois les convictions religieuses et la
pratique religieuse est pour moi si on
arrivait à voir dans ce texte cette
espèce de faîtage qui permettrait de
rappeler ce principe là dans cette loi
là ça permettra ensuite dirigé les
articles sion pour nous de bien rappeler
le fil directeur qui qui est celle là
donc je
j'espère que nos apporteurs l'on vient
d'entendre en tout cas je trouve c'est
une belle proposition que vous avez fait
ce matin
merci monsieur monsieur dans le droit
fil de ce que vient de dire monsieur
hervé c'est vrai que je vous remercie
pour cet apport à l'article 1 mais je
voulais faire observer que comme il l'a
dit lui-même monsieur revêt la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et la constitution actuelle
contiennent déjà finalement cela et j'ai
été aussi très intéressés par le fait
que vous critiquez finalement très peu
ce texte et alors comme j'ai une
sensation bizarre je me suis dit allons
nous être au chômage parce qu'il n'y
aurait rien n'a changé je voulais vous
demander s'il y avait encore quelques
perfection qui dans votre esprit
manquerez à ce texte
c'est la première question est la
deuxième vous avez dit qu'il valait
lutter contre le radicalisme en disant
des choses positives
vous savez nous avons travaillé il ya
quelques temps avait justement nathalie
goulet en or et reichardt sur le
radicalisme et nous avons vu tous les
vendeurs de poudre de perlimpinpin qui
disent voilà on va vous faire un stage
en trois semaines
et vous allez être des radicaliser ou
alors on va vous présenter quatre vidéos
et vous allez être des radicaliser vous
savez quand quelqu'un a décidé radical
dans la tête il y croit et qu'est ce qui
va faire qui va croire autre chose voir
le contraire c'est pas simple comme
sujet et on peut faire des messages sur
internet on peut même envoyer des ddd
texte mais je ne suis pas sûr sera de
l'effet qu'est ce qui peut faire
finalement qu'on lutte
effectivement j'ai une réponse l'école
publique laïque républicaine mais son
emprise n'est peut-être pas assez forte
aujourd'hui parce que en fait on fait un
texte sur beaucoup de choses
et le problème qui est posé c'est celui
là
si monsieur alors monsieur la charte et
madame gatel et ensuite monsieur gérard
va répondre a justement d'un jeu je me
permets de vous poser des questions que
j'ai posées à représentants des cultes
qui ont bien voulu se présenter devant
nous avant vous rien dans ce texte sur
la qualification la formation des
ministres du culte
or à n'en pas douter
l'absence de qualification donne un
grand nombre d'imams dans ce pays abouti
ou à d'ores et déjà abouti à une
certaine radicalisation de certains de
leurs fidèles donc ma question est très
direct
ne pensez-vous pas que devrait
apparaître dans ce texte une exigence de
qualification des ministres du culte ce
qui effacerait naturellement par la
définition d'un ministre du culte
alors on objecte que ça consisterait à
organiser la religion non pour moi non
c'est simplement une exigence de
qualification qui serait stipulait à
charge naturellement pour les religions
de déterminer le niveau de cette
qualification qui devrait l'assurer etc
etc moi pour moi c'est simplement une
question d'ordre public vraiment d'or vu
j'en profite pour ajouter une autre une
autre question
ce texte manifestement il s'appelait à
l'époque lutte contre les séparatismes
maintenance et la conformation des
valeurs républicaines ou du principe
vient vous le savez bien il l'effet
initialement clairement pour lutter
contre les dérives de de l'islam
politique et j'ai le sentiment quand
même que à cet égard là le compte n'y
est pas pour le titre personnel le
compte n'y est pas notamment on est en
train de mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de dispositions nouvelles sur les
associations on en a parlé et c'est par
exemple même si on met de l'ordre
mais si les associations doivent rendre
de comptes sur le plan financier sur les
flux etc
il ya des choses qui restent encore très
largement au pack très largement tupac
pardon c'est par exemple chez les
musulmans
le halal et le pèlerinage le hajj très
clairement si on veut mettre de l'ordre
dans les associations il faut peut-être
regarder aussi ce qui se passe dans ces
deux domaines et ce faisant je rejoins
la question tout à l'heure de nathalie
goulet est ce que
e
le fait que le gouvernement n'ait pas
voulu mettre dans son projet de loi
d'aidé des dispositions concernant par
exemple le halal n'est pas lié au fait
qu effectivement il y as chez vous
le cacher qu'ils posent aucun souci
enfin en termes de transparence
est ce que vous seriez gêner si nous
envisagions de rajouter l'un ou l'autre
élément de ce type pour améliorer la
transparence des flux financiers dans ce
texte notamment pour ce qui concerne le
halal voilà et je rejoins la question de
monsieur luxure tout à l'heure qu'est ce
que vous nous proposez rice et le cas
échéant d'ajouter pour aller dans le
sens recherché de lutte contre le
radicalisme entre guillemets religieux
merci merci dernière question de même
qu'à tel merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le président monsieur je voudrais vous
remercier pour cet esprit de dialogue
que vous savez toujours nourrir à la
fois avec gravité exigences et
bienveillance ma question est assez
simple
monsieur elle a trait aux phénomènes que
nous constatons aujourd'hui lié à la
montée de l'antisémitisme certains
citoyens de confession de culture juive
ont enlevé leurs enfants des écoles de
la république pour se protéger il ne
s'agit plus là simplement d'avoir la
liberté de pratiquer sa religion ou de
suivre un enseignement toléré par les
lois de la république mais
confessionnelles simplement parce qu'ils
ont peur qu'ils prennent et qu'ils sont
en danger tel constat dressez-vous
aujourd'hui deux de ces départs et de
cette situation je remercie la
présidente
sinon je trouve une remarquable
cohérence dans ses c'est quatre
questions cinq questions j'essaie de
répondre très rapidement parce que où
ils apprennent à un public en fait on y
réfléchissant et souvent la question
remarquable de le rencontrer c'est une
réaffirmation de la volonté des
principes républicains m de madère donc
s'il s'agit même pas de signer quelque
chose une fois tous les cinq ans c'est
semaine après semaine nous infirmons et
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
chaque fois dans l'histoire
chaque fois que la république était
forte le judaïsme était serein chaque
fois que la république a flanché en 1895
au moment de l' affaire dreyfus est
tellement il y avait une hyper fragilité
de la république il y avait des forces
anti républicaine
sachant qu'à à oran par exemple qui
était la france à l'époque à oran un
maire sur une liste antisémite est élu
c'était un maire qui se définit comme
antimite et les pas d'autres partis que
l'antisémitisme
il est élu donc la république est
fragile la situation des juifs est
compliqué puis la république l'emportent
et la sl sont des juifs se stabilise les
juifs s'engage dans la première guerre
mondiale mondiale de manière incroyable
et lorsque la république ton dans 40
l'association des juifs est
catastrophique donc c'est simple
équation est pour moi est simple
république forte égale judaïsme serein
république fragile e république en
danger et garder judaïsme fragilisons
danger voilà ma réponse est je crois que
ça ça déroule finalement une sorte de
d'obsession républicaine que pierre
birnbaum avait appelé dans un livre
incroyable les fous de la république les
fous de la république ce que je lise a
toujours été je rappelle une fois de
plus de la devise du consistoire
religion et patrie la question de
l'utilisateur le qu'hervé est formidable
vraiment c'est très important
c'est effectivement une liberté de
pratique religieuse est malheureusement
souvent les gens l'oublient
non mais il ya une liberté de conscience
tant la liberté de conscience chez soi
la troisième république jour de le dire
devant une professeur d'histoire qui
parlait alors de le ph et dont
effectivement les romains étaient très
souvent diplômés j'étais quand même ils
étaient les animateurs je pense a
regretté dans le 26 mai la trois
république disait que les juifs devaient
vivre comme des français à l'extérieur
et des juifs à la maison ce qui voulait
dire 100 % du temps schizophrène la
réalité c'est que nous sommes français
et juifs partout tout le temps à la
maison
dehors tout le temps parce que ce que
nous apportons chacun dans sa différence
dans son niveau de pratique ou dans son
athéisme dans sa religion chacun comme
il l'entend ce que nous apportons la
république c'est notre façon de la
construire par nos gestes par nos
engagements par notre pratique et donc
limiter la religion comme trop souvent
certains le font à une sorte de liberté
de conscience bas j'espère bien qu'on va
pas contrôler ce que je pense seul
l'éternel oserais-je dire ici sont des
reins et les coeurs
autrement dit c'est bien la liberté de
pratique religieuse qui est importante
et il faut le rappeler
effectivement la limite c'est l'ordre
public que je n'empêche personne de
vivre sa foi librement que je ne gêne
pas les roulements je vois que qu'on
fasse pas des manifestations de rue
chaque fois qu'on doit aller de on
demande l'autorisation préfectorale
comme n'importe quel autre organisme qui
doit utiliser l'espace public la
question si vous permettez de faire
presque une tautologie germes ce center
c'est que oui le titre de la loi c'est
le rappel des principes républicains ou
réaffirmation des rapides donc oui vous
avez raison
évidemment raison ça se trouve dans la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme se trouve dans l'article 1er de
mais si on est déjà à rappeler les gens
importants de rappelons le rappelons le
juste pour dire non les religions ne
sont pas une menace pour la société
au point que nous ayons besoin de les
encadrer nous avons besoin ensemble avec
les religions de construire un espace de
confiance
c'est ça qui me paraît important et
c'est ce que j'espère voir dans l'âme
dans la loi vous avez posé une question
essentielle qu'est ce que je proposerai
c'est simple le président du consistoire
joël mergui a fait une proposition que
je trouve toujours c'est qu'il faut
quand même si on veut faire basculer
toutes les associations qui font du
culte dans le web 900 / 1905 il faut
donner des avantages pour le faire alors
ils proposent par exemple que la
défiscalisation soit 2 75 % des dons
comme ça l'est pour par exemple à
l'assaut du coeur en gros vous
êtes vous faites du culte dans une 1905
plus contrôlés plus contrôlable plus fin
plus cohérente
alors on vous donne l avantage après
vous trouvez d'autres avantages mais
c'est justement votre travail peut être
de proposer une amélioration pour
trouver des incitations à ce que les
associations près faire basculer dans le
1905 à 90% ces méfaits voilà voilà
enfin économistes j'ose dire je fais
attention je fais très attention à ce
que je dis si vous avez vraiment
tellement raison sur le radicalisme
j'y crois pas oui comment j'ai aimé
votre formulation poudre de perlimpinpin
donné raison vous êtes tellement raison
que en gros
l'enjeu n'est plus de des radicalités
mais de faire en sorte que leur discours
ne soit pas audible par d'autres ce sont
les autres qu'il faut contrer et le
contre-discours il est pas pour des
radicaliser les méchants il est pour
empêcher les méchants de rendre méchant
d'autres et donc par exemple on a fait
un programme incroyable qui s'appelle
aladin avec la fondation pour la mémoire
de la shoah qui consiste à diffuser
gratuitement sur internet
les textes comme si c'est un homme le
journal d'anne frank traduits en persan
ourdou en arabe en farsi en toutes les
langues et libre de droit accessible sur
internet pour que la jeunesse de ces
pays puissent aller trouver les textes
ne soient pas que porter celle cherche
des informations sur la choix ne soit
pas immédiatement dans un site
conspirationnistes un site que veut dire
qu'il ya rien négationnistes donc oui il
faut manifester
le principe de de lutte y compris par du
contre discours mais pas pour les
méchants je pense que c'est trop tard
mais pour ce qu'ils cherchent à
embrigader jambes ce sénateur et
charbonneux et 10 fois raison la
formation des musiques cultes mais je
sens que dans ce texte il essaie de ne
pas rentrer dans la gestion interne des
cultes et la formation c'est le coeur du
coeur de métier de ce que font du coup
de com en forme les rabbins les pasteurs
les prêtres imams
donc oui c'est tellement vrai ce que
vous dites il faut empêcher que les gens
mais que les gens utilisent des imams
inadéquat on commence déjà
et je crois que le présent dans plus de
l'annoncé à dire qu'en 1900 en 2024
il n'y aura plus
d'imam enfin je fais attention ici chez
que dans cette enceinte on fait
attention que les passeports
diplomatiques mais il n'y aura plus
l'imam avec des passeports diplomatiques
d'autres pays je sais que certains ici
sont très attentifs
mais une fois qu'on les enlève une fois
qu'on les ait en 24 il faudra bien les
remplacer par des imams formés en france
de ce point de vue là le ph et a son
rôle à jouer
l'école pratique des hautes études
l'institut catholique a des choses à
faire
la faculté de strasbourg a des choses à
faire et puis les instances musulmanes
sont elles aussi capable de produire de
la formation d'imams elles ont le temps
pour le faire il faut juste les
accompagner dans cette vocation pour le
hadj à l'oral vous avez raison il faut
absolument que puisse ramener ces flux
financiers vers les instances
communautaires et pavés de verre des
intérêts particuliers
mais ça et pas besoin de loi pour
contrôler les choses sur un bon tiers
des impôts que franchement ça marche
très bien croyez-moi les flux financiers
sont traçables ici si c'était tout à
force du gym qui a considéré un moment
que le produit de la viande casher
devait aller à la communauté globalement
parce que on fait on on c'est une sorte
de redistribution donc après il faut une
péréquation entre les communes terrer
chez les coen été pour voir enfin même
si un set vous soulever une question
très douloureuse mais l'absence
d'enfants juifs dans l'école publique
dans certains endroits et c'est une
réalité qui date depuis en tout cas
depuis 2002 un peu sans beaucoup d'échos
d'ailleurs malheureusement 2002 il ya un
livre qui sort qui s'appelle était
perdue de république et qui dénoncent
cette situation
bien entendu on fait taire les auteurs
on les traite de tous les noms
on les accuse de briser le pacte
républicain vingt ans après
dix neuf ans après ça me dit obligé de
constater qu'il avait malheureusement
raison est que là où chaque endroit où
les élèves juste ne pouvait pas trouver
leur place
eh bien vous vingt ans après nous
pouvons constater la baisse de niveau
d'engagement républicains une sorte
d'abandon et je crois que collectivement
on où je comprends je comprends les
parents moi je suis un enfant d'école
publique et je comprends les parents qui
mettent leurs enfants dans le privé
catholique il faut rendre hommage ou
l'école privée catholique qui
accueillent ces enfants dans le privé
laïc mais je crois que ce l'on peut pas
se satisfaire d'une situation dans
lequel il est plus d'espérance et moi je
crois profondément dans l'école
républicaine et que le kiki est toujours
sert l'école privée religieuse est aussi
une école républicaine et moi je peux
vous dire que j'ai mis ma fille dans une
école uniquement parce qu'en rentrant
dans le bureau de la directrice
j'ai vu la photo du ravivage de la
flamme que j'organisais lorsque j'étais
ont mené des armées et lorsque j'étais
dans les armées je faisais venir des
écoles pour venir chanter la
marseillaise sous l'arc de triomphe
quand j'ai vu dans le bureau de sa
directrice cette photo je dis madame si
vous êtes d'accord je le mette ma fille
chez vous à cause de cette photo parce
que je pense que malgré le caractère
prof des écoles on vit la même espérance
républicaine et peu importe comment on
la vit dans la mesure où on arrive à la
vivre ensemble alors on retrouve un
espace de ce qu'est la république
[Musique]